we go now to our Fox News Alert the
republican-controlled house just passed
a major piece of legislation that
slashes Joe Biden's Reckless spending
while also raising the debt ceiling now
keep in mind for months it's about 84
days Joe Biden has been refusing to meet
with Republican lawmakers especially the
speaker Kevin McCarthy he was comparing
Republicans to terrorists he wouldn't
even have a conversation with the
speaker no instead Biden demanded that
the speaker pass a budget raised a debt
limit without input from the White House
so earlier tonight speaker McCarthy the
Republican party in the house they did
just that and now if Biden stands in the
way Joe Biden and the Democrats they
will be the ones responsible for any
future default of this country take a
look
then you said could we stand up for the
American public that we said in a
commitment to America that we would pass
the parents Bill of Rights we passed
that we've said when we put forth hr1
that we just stand firm to make our
energy independent in America and build
our economy we passed that we looked and
said when we watched Washington D.C
decriminalized every form of crime that
we stood up the first time in 30 years
at Congress to do that and you all asked
me the same question what's going to
happen when the Senate stops it well the
Senate didn't stop it it passed it
what's going to happen when the
president said beforehand why'd you even
vote on it because he wasn't going to
sign it he signed it all right joining
us now with more house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy is with us Mr Speaker how are
you
[Music]
all right
so the CBO scored your bill and it shows
that over 10 years you will save the
American taxpayer a whopping 4.8
trillion and now that is in exchange to
raise the debt ceiling however that's
only this year's negotiation you're only
raising it one year right that is right
and it is the largest saving of a bill
in American history that's what we just
passed with the fourth seat again
if you did it with 217 votes I did talk
to Congressman Mack H he said if the
vote was tomorrow he would he would vote
with you but he didn't like the process
and some amendments added late
um let's tell the American people what
else is in this bill and why this is so
important and the more important
question is will all Republicans stand
firm when the Democrats try to cut back
and pair back your savings
well I need everybody to stand firm with
us even those four who voted against it
as well what this bill is its limits
save grow you want to limit the ability
to government to grow so fast like it
did on the Democrats going forward so we
capped the growth at one percent each
year for the next 10. we save money by
being smart what we do is that money and
billions of dollars sitting out there
that covid never spent just sitting
there we claw that back so the American
taxpayer can save the money we put in
work requirements to help people get
jobs to move forward help our supply
chain and get our country moving again
you know what else we do by limiting the
amount we spend we curve inflation that
makes people stronger then we want to
grow our economy HR One lowering our
energy cost we lower the energy costs
for all Americans but we also create
more jobs we cut the red tape so we
could build things again in America
that's just a small sampling of what we
do in this bill and we also cut eighty
seven thousand IRS agents so government
is here to help you not go after you
uh that might be one of my favorite
Provisions definitely
um I want people to understand
most people may not get what Baseline
budgeting is but the government builds
into every year an increase in every
Department usually you know six seven
eight nine percent and you're going to
limit that to a maximum of one percent
correct correct remember what they did
with that Omnibus at the end of the year
last year they jammed it through in the
increased spending by 132 billion
dollars for the next year but that costs
a lot well go ahead cost you 1.5 billion
over 10 years what we simply do is we
pull the dollar figure back to 2022.
what we were spending just four months
ago and the president goes out there and
says we're we're gonna we're gonna
starve babies we're gonna cut people off
head start or something that's not true
just four months ago we were able to
achieve all that well wait a minute I
have a question waste and Joe Biden
claimed when he said he was well when he
recorded his announcement that he's
going to run for reelection because he
couldn't do it live and get it right
um
foreign
did accuse Republicans of wanting to gut
and cut Social Security is there any
truth to that Congressman because I
don't know of a single Republican that
wants to do that none whatsoever but you
know who is cutting Social Security
Medicare President Biden for the first
time in the history of any president
based upon all the money he spent the
Congressional budget office came out
with a report it's the first time in a
10-year window that not only the highway
trust fund but Medicare and Social
Security go and solve it so what that
means is that automatic cut to those
because the president's action of what
he's taken Republicans today took
actions to make it stronger by putting
in work requirements putting more people
at work paying into it we curve
inflation that helps save Medicare and
Social Security and the most important
thing we do we cut our dependency on
China and we bring the jobs back to
America where they should so I
that I want to share with you and that
is I I told you very early on when you
became speaker that we would hold you
accountable and you kept This Promise
here thank you for doing that on the
other hand I'm saying to every
Republican that voted for this bill
today that you must hold the line and
not give an inch to the Democrats
because they're going to try and water
this down every which way and sideways
so uh if you can get your caucus to hold
the line that'll be a successful Chevy
American
Sean you should thank every Republican
who voted for this bill because they
went out and they fought hard those who
did not vote for the bill they ought to
hold with us because it makes us weaker
that we don't have a hundred percent and
we're doing exactly what we told the
American people to do we keep the
commitment to America and we'll continue
to come on here promises made Promises
Kept and we are just getting started hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else